[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous déjà je
tenais à vous remercier pour être venu
si nombreux et sinon nombreuses dans ma
plus tendre enfance il y a un trait de
caractère très fréquent qui s'est
développé c'est la curiosité cette
curiosité qui m'a fait démonter
redémonter remonter le camion de Noël
que ma mère m'offre à Noël à son plus
grand désarroi c'est la même curiosité
qui m'a poussé à développer mes
compétences et de voguer de services en
service hospitalier pendant nombreuses
années j'ai fait de la chirurgie
cardiaque du bloc opératoire enfin tout
un tas de services et c'est cette même
curiosité qui m'a poussé à développer
des compétences dans le domaine de la
blockchain depuis maintenant 4 ans
je suis romain Bailleul d'infirmiers
entrepreneurs du web 3 il paraît que
j'ai un parcours étonnant j'espère que
après cette conférence vous allez tous
être convaincu que chacun peut choisir
son propre chemin son propre destin peu
importe du qu'en dira-t-on
alors ici dans cette salle si je vous
posez la question qu'est-ce que c'est
que web 3 je suis persuadé que très peu
de personnes seraient capables de donner
une définition claire et simple mais
rassurez-vous aucun problème il y a de
nombreuses experts de ce domaine qui
sont même pas capables eux-mêmes d'en
donner une définition
un point commun selon moi dans toutes
les technologies disruptives qui ont
changé le monde et le quotidien de
milliards d'êtres humains c'est la data
et oui c'est bien il y a l'information
sa production sont stockage sa
transmission et sa distribution qu'on a
des révolutions technologiques qui ont
bouleversé le quotidien de millions
d'êtres humains d'ailleurs ce n'est pas
pour rien mon sens que le point de
rupture entre la préhistoire et
l'histoire se situe au début de
l'écriture le point fondamental c'est à
dire c'est bien via la data et
l'information quand on a commencé à
écrire on est passé de la préhistoire à
l'histoire
d'une autre manière une autre révolution
fondamentale c'était l'imprimerie
Gutenberg a permis de rendre accessible
de la data de l'information au plus
grand nombre c'est ce qui a permis à
rendre la Bible accessible à des
millions de personnes ce qui a changé et
bouleversé le quotidien de toute
l'Europe de tous les Européens et qui a
fondamentalement changé l'histoire
toujours sur le côté de la data et
d'information on peut avoir d'autres
révolutions qui ont changé la face du
monde vous avez bien sûr la télévision
qui a changé notre rapport à la
consommation changer de rapport au
divertissement on a évidemment aussi
internet Ethernet est devenu tellement
présent dans nos vies qu'on l'oublie
Internet et là maintenant ici dans ma
poche internet me permet de passer les
slides on a internet dans notre voiture
enfin bref aujourd'hui c'est les
technologies qui sont devenues tellement
banales qu'on les oublie
pour ma part
ma vie a été complètement bouleversée
par trois révolutions fondamentales la
première comme vous le voyez ici bon
c'est pas moi j'étais plus beau que ça
quand j'étais jeune
c'est l'arrivée de l'ordinateur dans ma
chambre dans ma chambre d'adolescence du
jour au lendemain je me retrouve avec
une machine sur lequel je tapote et je
me retrouve avec une encyclopédie c'est
pour moi finalement la bibliothèque de
Babylone aujourd'hui les gens trouvent
que c'est normal d'avoir accès à ces
informations là mais rendez-vous compte
vous avez accès à la bibliothèque de
Babylone directement dans votre
ordinateur j'avais accès à une
encyclopédie qui me permettait de me
former de m'informer de me cultiver de
développer mes compétences sans avoir
acheté un bouquin sans avoir à louer
sans même aller à la bibliothèque
j'avais tout là juste devant chez moi
deuxième chose deuxième élément
fondamental c'était internet là ici vous
le voyez c'est un modem 56K certains ici
ont peut-être connus c'était une machine
infernale qui faisait abri pas possible
toujours est-il que cette machine
infernale m'a donné accès à une
information actualisée quasiment en
temps réel je pouvais m'informer je
pouvais me former d'autant plus et je
pouvais développer ma curiosité vers
tous les champs des possibles avec une
connexion qui était à l'époque bien sûr
pas terrible mais toujours est-il que
c'était déjà pour moi vraiment une vraie
révolution
la troisième c'est la blockchain la
blockchain a vraiment complètement
changé ma vie
si vous voulez très simplement on est
ici pour vulgariser les choses la
blockchain est à l'échange de valeur ce
qu'internet à l'échange d'informations
ma découverte du Bitcoin dans les années
2016-2017 je découvre ce bazar un peu un
peu bizarre et quand je gratte un petit
peu ben en fait ça m'a organisé de
nombreuses insomnies j'étais plus
capable de dormir je me suis dit que
j'étais là face à une révolution
totalement disruptive qui allait changer
non seulement ma vie et la vie de
nombreuses personnes et donc j'étais
face à une peut-être une pensée naïve
utopiste que sais-je mais je m'étais dit
que cette technologie là elle est
vraiment réellement changer l'impact de
nos vies futures
d'infirmière entrepreneurs alors comment
à votre avis on change la blouse pour un
sweat une casquette et on passe
d'infirmière entrepreneurs en fait très
simplement j'ai passé environ une
décennie dans le milieu de la santé je
voulais tout à l'heure j'ai pas mal
baroudé j'ai fait de nombreux et
services je vais pas tous vous les
évoquer parce que j'ai un CV long comme
mon bras j'ai été dans de nombreux
services et à chaque fois je voguer de
service en service en service et je me
posais une question je me dis mais
qu'est-ce qui se passe je comprends pas
à chaque fois que j'ai dans ce nouveau
service hospitalier il y avait de moins
en moins de moyens humains et financiers
je voyais des collègues qui faisaient
des burnouts je veux des collègues
tomber je voyais mes patients dans leur
regard je voyais que je n'avais pas
assez de temps à la raconter accorder ma
qualité de prise en charge de prise en
soin diminuer progressivement et j'étais
face à un paradoxe j'avais envie de
donner j'avais vraiment envie d'apporter
une qualité de prise en charge et de
moins en moins j'étais capable de
pouvoir la donner donc je me suis dit
mais qu'est-ce qui se passe comment
pourquoi
et c'est à ce moment donné j'ai commencé
à gratter un petit peu plus j'ai
découvert ce qu'on appelait à
tarification à l'acte la T2A alors la
tarification lac très simplement c'est
un système de codification et surtout de
tarification du parcours de santé et du
parcours de patient très simplement ça a
un système qui permet entre guillemets
de d'industrialiser de parcours de soins
et de le rentabiliser rentabiliser le
soin vous rendez compte rentabilisez
l'humain comment moi je pouvais accepter
ça alors ça m'a posé d'autres questions
je me suis dit bah si problème c'est
l'argent le manque d'argent à la base de
la base c'est quoi l'argent d'où vient
l'argent commande un jour au troquer des
coquillages et à mon nez on a dit bah
c'est un morceau de papier ça vaut
quelque chose
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé finalement
dans l'histoire de la monnaie comment se
sont passés les échanges financiers une
banque centrale mais comment ça marche
comment fonctionne les systèmes
monétaires et finalement au fur et à
mesure où j'ai gratté gratté et je vais
te dire que j'ai encore passé des
nombreuses nuits blanches j'ai d'une
certaine manière découverte beauté rose
et je me suis dit ben je sors d'un
milieu je suis dans un milieu de la
santé qui me correspond plus tout à fait
parce que je peux plus je peux plus te
donner ce que je veux et en fait je
découvre quelque chose qui a encore plus
iniquitable et qui a encore moins
légitime et donc c'est à ce moment donné
là où en fait j'ai commencé à ça on a où
j'ai vraiment découvert le Bitcoin et où
je me suis dit tiens là je tiens quelque
chose c'est un peu comme si j'avais tiré
sur une ficelle et d'un seul coup je
tirais de pompon
alors le web 3 c'est quoi
bah bien sûr vous doutez bien si on
parle du web 3 c'est qu'il y a une
chronologie il y a un Webin web 2 à web
3 on n'a pas sorti un web 3 comme ça du
jour au lendemain c'est évident le web 1
très simplement l'avait évoqué tout à
l'heure avec les débuts d'Internet
c'était une technologie qui nous permet
de lire les choses de manière totalement
passive on pouvait pas interagir mais
c'était déjà pas mal puis est arrivé le
web 2 le web 2 a rajouté non notion
fanables c'est d'écrire on peut
interagir on est plus juste passif face
à l'information on peut interagir avec
cette technologie de nombreux pensent
que c'est via l'arrivée des réseaux
sociaux c'est faux au tout départ
c'était les blogs les blogs qui vous
permettaient de produire du contenu de
le stocker en ligne de partager à vos
amis à votre famille à des communautés
et même à des inconnus
il y a par contre il y a une grosse
problématique avec deux alors certains
penseront peut-être que c'est le défi
stupide sur Tik Tok peut-être mais pas
que la vraie problématique du web 2
c'est quoi c'est qu'en fait on a eu
l'émergence de mastodontes comme les
gafams qui se sont appropriés vos data
pour mieux les monétiser comme le dit
l'adage si c'est gratuit c'est vous le
produit donc ça pose quand même une
certaine problématique toujours est-il
que c'était déjà une évolution c'était
déjà pas mal
et ensuite le web 3 est arrivé donc le
web 3 c'est quand même une notion qui
est quand même assez assez récente il y
a deux ans le web 3 on en parlait même
pas maintenant ça peut pas prêt un an un
an et demi ça fera de ma part qu'on
commence à parler de tout ce web 3 en
fait le web 3 c'est une notion de
blockchain de décentralisation et
surtout une notion de propriété avec le
web 3 vous allez pouvoir vous allez
pouvoir être propriétaire de vos data de
vos actifs et vous allez pouvoir
finalement reprendre le pouvoir enfin
c'est à dire les déceptions que le web
te a donné par rapport à nos espoirs de
liberté et nos espoirs de devenir
vraiment acteur c'est le web toi qu'il
est qui les apporte
mais alors à quoi ça sert parce que
c'est bien beau Romain tu nous parles de
web 3 etc mais il faut bien qu'il y a un
usage parce que finalement une
technologie on s'intéresse que parce
qu'elle est utile dans nos vies et bien
si vous voyez là ici vous voyez mesdames
Michu alors c'est qui Madame Michu mais
la Michu c'est ma grand-mère c'est ma
mère c'est votre cousine c'est votre
belle-sœur Madame Michu c'est tout le
monde et ces personnes à la fois madame
michut c'est de représentation mentale
de la française moyenne gros pendant son
mental de quelqu'un qui s'intéresse pas
forcément à la technologie
maintenant je vous demande de réfléchir
un petit peu on pense à Madame Michu
elle a eu son travail elle doit rentrer
à sa machine à laver elle a différentes
problématiques et elle passe dans son
épicerie Cartier après son travail et
elle passe devant le comptoir et elle
paie sans contact et elle part est-ce
que vous pensez qu'à ce moment donné
cette fameuse Madame Michu à ne
serait-ce qu'une notion des technologies
qui lui permet de payer sans contact
absolument pas d'ailleurs même moi non
plus et c'est ça qui est important et
fondamental et c'est d'ailleurs une
reproche que je fais aux acteurs de
notre écosystème et je mets je me mets
moi-même dedans c'est à dire qu'on a
beaucoup trop parlé de NFC de Smart
contracte de métaphes je vous parle même
pas de zérololage proof alors que
pourtant je peux vous assurer que c'est
une technologie qui est intéressante
mais ce qui est fondamental c'est quoi
c'est la valeur d'usage à quoi ça sert
qu'est-ce qu'on va en faire et j'aime
bien encore mieux à quel moment donner
la technologie s'efface
pour l'usage et l'adoption qu'on en fait
la technologie devient intéressante
quand on y pense même plus quand on
quand on s'intéresse même plus au fait
que on a une technologie mais qu'elle
répond juste à un besoin
du coup évidemment on va parler de cas
d'usage concret je vous parle pas de
dans 10 ans dans 20 ans je parle pas de
Star Wars de Stargate etc pourtant je
suis un vrai fan de science-fiction je
vous parle de cas d'usage dans le monde
réel dans le monde de maintenant le
premier on a déjà un peu discuté tout à
l'heure c'est des systèmes de paiement
via le Bitcoin par exemple il y a une
vraie problématique c'est que Bitcoin on
lui dit tout et son contraire par
rapport à lui c'est de l'ordre du
numérique c'est de ceci c'est de cela
faux au tout départ le Bitcoin a été
inventé comme un système de paiement
point barre rien de plus et ça
malheureusement de nombreux de nombreux
lobbies
la deuxième cas d'usage ici je sais pas
si vous vous en rappelez au Stade de
France il y avait une sacrée covue je
dirais même un bazar où tout le monde se
montait dessus par rapport à un stade de
foot ça avait même fait le tour des
médias on avait été la risée du monde
entier et les Anglais se sont pas gênés
pour se de nous à tort à raison
peu importe c'est pas le sujet si on
avait utilisé technologies blockchain je
peux vous assurer que ça ne serait pas
arrivé d'ailleurs même ici dans cette
salle vous ne le savez peut-être pas
mais votre Ticket est un NFC c'est un
jeton non fongible qui est infasifiable
et qui garantit de votre droit légitime
à assister à cette conférence et vous
vous êtes quasiment de pouvoir peut-être
même pas rendu compte c'est ça qui est
intéressant
deuxième un troisième cas d'usage les
diplômes on parle d'un fassifiable un
ticket on peut le rendre à falsifiable
on peut le rendre traçable bah pourquoi
pas et bien sachez que à Lille à Paris à
Marseille de manière assez marginale
aujourd'hui mais en tout cas ça commence
déjà à se mettre en place on utilise la
blockchain pour certifier des diplômes
imaginez-vous un monde plus sûr dans
lequel on va pouvoir remettre de la
confiance entre une future recrue et un
recruteur quelle valeur ça c'est une
valeur vraiment intéressante parce qu'on
remet de la confiance finalement dans
ces relations ou certains membres
certains rangent leur CV ou autre et bah
là ça n'êtes plus besoin les diplômes
sont infasifiables traçables
authentiques
on parle de d'authenticité j'en viens
directement à l'art
depuis des centaines d'années on a même
des on a on a des copies de qui ont été
fait au 14e siècle au 15e siècle
certains experts aujourd'hui citrons ils
ne savent pas distinguer une vraie d'une
fausse œuvre d'art et c'est une réelle
problématique et bien grâce aux
technologies blockchain on va pouvoir
déterminer l'authenticité d'une oeuvre
d'art et ça lui donnera d'autant plus de
valeur
de la même manière dans le luxe dans le
luxe comment vous allez définir d'une
vraie Rolex d'une fausse c'est compliqué
d'ailleurs même des experts citrons
parce que finalement qu'est-ce qui
ressemble à plus à une Rolex qu'une
autre c'est exactement la même chose et
bien tout comme dans l'art nous allons
pouvoir du coup apporter de la
traçabilité et de la sécurité de la
confiance dans ces éléments là
d'ailleurs vous avez peut-être le savoir
la fraude ça coûte des milliards d'euros
chaque année et ça tombe souvent
pas dans les bonnes poches tout
l'intérêt de la blockchain ça va être
justement de rapporter de la confiance
la blockchain est avant tout une
technologie de confiance ça c'est
quelque chose que vous devez intégrer
j'étais obligé d'en parler du mieux de
la santé j'ai passé une décennie dans ce
milieu j'étais obligé de parler de cas
d'usage dans le milieu de la santé vous
ne savez peut-être pas mais
l'information la data sa transmission sa
qualification ou pas ça peut engendrer
de graves conséquences qui peuvent même
aller jusqu'à la mort oui jusqu'à la
mort une mauvaise information une
perfusion parce que qui était faite
alors que on n'a pas pris en compte les
allergies ça peut amener vraiment
jusqu'à la mort et donc imaginez-vous un
monde où on pourrait par exemple tracer
votre groupe sanguin vos allergies les
relire votre identité on les anonymisant
bien sûr et bien tous ces problématiques
là seraient réglées
projetez-vous encore un peu plus
imaginez-vous un monde dans lequel on va
pouvoir recouper toutes ces datas les
croiser les recouper et cela pourrait
servir la recherche médicale comme vous
le voyez
là je vous parle pas de trucs de geek je
vous parle de votre quotidien je vous
parle du mien je vous parle de notre
réalité c'est pas de la science-fiction
j'aurais pu vous faire une liste de cas
d'usage long comme mon bras mais
vraiment je vous rappelle en faire des
dizaines et des dizaines j'ai voulu vous
en donner des très simples relativement
parlant qui vous paraissent cohérent et
qui vous interpelle
comme je disais lors d'une conférence à
une vision conférence devant plus de 150
assureurs si vous aimez vos enfants
formez-les à la blockchain c'est ce que
j'aurais dit il y a 20 ans c'était pour
avoir internet c'était exactement la
même chose la blockchain faut savoir une
chose c'est que aujourd'hui il y a de
nombreuses opportunités qui émergent
d'ailleurs je connais de nombreux
entrepreneurs que rien ne prédestiné à
être là où ils en sont et pourtant il
développe des projets qui sont
fondamentalement disruptifs et
passionnant d'ailleurs moi-même rien ne
me prédestiné à la base à être là devant
vous qu'est-ce qui m'a poussé être avant
mon parcours et être là
jusqu'aujourd'hui devant vous c'est ma
curiosité c'est mon envie d'apprendre
c'est ma passion et c'est ce qui m'a
amené finalement à être conférencier
devant vous ici dans cette conférence
TEDx
demos Kratos
alors si je rêve et que je suis un peu
utopiste les technologies web 3
blockchain et de et de décentralisation
apporteront à l'humanité
finalement le pouvoir et le peuple via
ces données numériques via ses actifs et
via ses engagements
je vous remercie tous pour votre
attention et je vais faire une chose que
je ne fais jamais pour remercier je fais
tomber la casquette merci
[Applaudissements]